We take advantage of telling you that there is
simultaneous translation for those who require it.
Good afternoon to all of you,
especially to the President of the
European Union,
Úrsula Thunderlayen, to her entourage and to the
national and international press who are
with us. Today we are very happy
that Úrsula featured in her  It is the first time
that you are in Chile and in Latin America and
we are very grateful that you have
chosen Chile as one of the four
countries that you are going to visit on this
Latin American tour, in addition to Brazil,
Argentina and later Mexico,
this morning we have had a
very  fruitful in that
we have taken another step on the
important path and that does not end the
cooperation and multilateralism between
Chile and the European Union through the
signing of two instruments that will promote
the Green Hydrogen Industry in
our country whose development will undoubtedly
Contribute to improving the quality of life
of Chileans, as
Úrsula Fonderlay pointed out at the meeting we
had, the green hydrogen market
is skywalking, that is, it has
tremendous potential and Chile is one
of the countries best positioned to
take the lead in this matter.  This is
the joint declaration of
intent between the Ministry of
Finance and Corfo, the European
Investment Bank and the State Development Bank
of the Federal Republic of
Germany, which involves contributions of 216
million euros associated with the
National Green Hydrogen Strategy.
In addition, we have signed the declaration of the
Team Europe initiative for the
development of renewable hydrogen in
Chile between our Ministry of
Energy, the European Union and the
Federal Republic of Germany, which has
financing of eight million euros
for capacity building and
growth transfers on  support
for technological development among other
key objectives for the development of
this industry
this is good news for our
compatriots but also for the world
because the Green Hydrogen Industry
offers great opportunities to move
faster towards a green energy matrix
and indeed with the Union  European Union
we share the goal that we have set ourselves
closely to the Neutral Bond between now and
2050 we are both countries and the community of
the few that have passed a law to
precisely commit ourselves to this
objective, it also brings investment and
direct benefits for our country
because to the extent that  that the
green hydrogen strategy and our
participation in the world market
grows There will be more resources, a better
quality of life for everyone,
greater growth and a
fair distribution of this growth
Chile is already the leader in
clean energy in Latin America today and we are glad  It is
very much that our longstanding partners
in the European Union recognize this
leadership and are supporting us in
our plan to become the
most competitive Green hydrogen producers
on the planet by 2030
and it is especially valuable that the
interest of the European Union in Chile
materialize through concrete projects
that install capacities and build
key knowledge for the future of
our country and the world. In this way,
this industry will contribute a
value chain that includes knowledge,
training of workers,
first-rate technologies, and also respect and
care for the  naturaleza This is a
project approved by
the visit of the president of the
european commission As I told you, she is part
of a Latin American tour,
in addition to our country, she is visiting
Argentina, Brazil and Mexico and her visit to
Chile responds to the interest in
intensifying the relationship between Chile
and the  European Union But we have also
talked about other issues that are
important because the old relationship
between Chile and the European Union has been
acquiring a density that transforms
the European Union into one of our
main international partners, not
only in commercial terms but
also in cultural and political terms.
shared values ​​and at a time when
human rights and
democracy are under threat in the world,
deepening the ties between those of us who
have these shared values ​​is
tremendously important and relevant
we have a powerful harmony in
economic, social and legal matters we have
important bilateral relations with
each other  Of the 27 members of the union,
today the European Union is the main
foreign investor in our country
with 64 billion dollars
accumulated, which represents 26% of
foreign direct investment in Chile.
For all this, it is also worth
remembering that with  President Fonder
Lion celebrated in December the successful
conclusion of the
political negotiations for the modernization of the
European Union Chile association agreement and
everything indicates that we will be able to sign the
new advanced framework agreement framework
this year, which has
characteristics that I think are important to
highlight  Today, in the first place, it is a
transversal agreement of the Last Generation
that responds to the demands of our
citizens and places
global challenges such as
the climate crisis, the
digital revolution, at the center of people, and strengthens social cohesion and
also updates the areas of
cooperation.  between Chile and the
European Union around shared values ​​and
principles such as the promotion
of democracy, the defense of
human rights and
fundamental freedoms of the rule of law and
good governance, as well as
sustainable development, gender equality and
empowerment of women and girls,
we also talked about the possibilities that
open up with our
National Lithium strategy where
Úrsula fonder Lion has raised the
interest of the European Union and in fact
we are going to advance in it in an emojiu by
the way in a  framework of understanding
to be able to develop value here in
Chile regarding the Lithium Industry
that is not a mainly
extractive industry but that the value chain
is an important part here in our
country and for that the European Union has
expressed its interest in collaborating and
investing  And that is very good news,
we are certain that the next
summit in a couple of weeks between the
European Union and CELAC will be
crucial in deepening the ties
that unite both regions and that we will be
able to advance in well-being  of the
peoples, putting them at the center of the
discussion in which we will be
present in person as a country and
finally I cannot fail to mention
a topic that I have discussed with various
political leaders in the world, including
the president of the European Union
present here, the importance  that
respect for the international rules
that we have given ourselves has to be defended always and everywhere and for this reason it does not
lose force by repeating it, we
categorically and clearly condemn the invasion and
the war that Russia is carrying out
in Ukraine and we advocate for
the  respect for the
territorial integrity of Ukraine out of respect for
the life of its people
we condemn the latest bombings that
have killed civilians and by the way
we state that
respect for international rules
and the charter of the United Nations in
particular by all countries but
in particular for the most
powerful countries, it has to be made effective,
it has to be made effective. This is a
war that hurts us all so much in
terms of the loss of human lives,
what they are suffering there is unspeakable,
but also that it has concrete effects
on our population in terms of
inflation and the increase in the cost of
living and therefore we call on
the parties to quickly achieve peace thank you
very much and Úrsula welcome
it is a pleasure to have you here in our country
then the
president of the commission will speak  Mrs.
Úrsula fonderlayer
Thank you
welcome
Gabriel opinion
[Music] [
Applause]
We now continue with the questions from
thepress
Good afternoon President Good afternoon
President
Thank you for the opportunity My question
is for the president of the
European commission I am Javier Martín director of the
agency  from the
Spanish news agency agency director in Chile
after eight years of impasse the
European Union and the celac countries are going
to meet next July in Brussels
I wanted to know what are the objectives of
this meeting What are the ambitions
and hopes  What do you hope to achieve
in this meeting and in this context
to know
what is your assessment of the
statements by President Lula Silva,
for example, that the relationship with
Mercosur and other countries does not have to
be conditioned by mistrust
Thank you very much
Fernández
[Music]
good  Afternoons I am Pedro 8 Arce from
Agence France I wanted to ask you,
President, to expand a little
more. The topic of the conversation is that
you had with President Faner Legend
on the subject of lithium, if what
they discussed is more about the subject of
cooperation or I get a
trade association and if in that sense let
's say the European Union is
ahead of other potential
partners thank you
very much
lithium is a critical element to
address the fight against the
climate crisis a critical mineral and
in  Our country has abundant
reserves of this mineral
and Chile has to take care of
that and that is why we launched
the National Lithium Strategy a couple of months ago
where we stated that the state
is going to play an important role and through
public-private associations we are going to
develop  this industry, but not
only from an
extractivist perspective, but also improving
technology,
taking care of nature and, very importantly,
adding value
here we have the possibility not only of
extracting the mineral but also
of the value chain
transferring both
technology transfer and chaining
production occurs in part in
our country
And before that the president Fender Lion
has explicitly expressed the interest
of the European Union in contributing in that
direction,
therefore it is very good news
for Chile and in fact we have already agreed to
start the negotiations and  Hopefully, with regard
to our next visit to Europe, we can
already have advanced a framework of
understanding. In this matter, they
have told us that for them it is
very important that the
supply of lithium be diversified,
not only insist on the extraction
of the mineral, but also on the supply chain.  value
of it and in that Chile has an
important role to play an important role
to play with the mineral but also
with knowledge with its
universities with its
scientists and that is why we look very
favorably on what we have discussed
today with the  President Fonderline I think
it is very good news for Chile
and it is advancing in the direction that we have
proposed from the government to generate a
national industry
that lithium is a source of pride for all
Chileans just as copper has been
for so long this is
good news  for Chile and we see the
European Union as a strategic ally
in this matter
Hello, good afternoon. My name is
Karen Peña, a journalist from the
financial newspaper. My question is for the
president of the European Commission regarding
energy issues. Sorry, they were addressed in
the  meeting I would like to know if
the financial problems
faced by some renewable companies
in Chile were discussed and in this sense to know if the
European Commission is calmer with
the message transmitted by the government
Thank you very much
President President Gabriel
What information do you have on the
registered explosive attacks  In different
regions of the country in recent days
we know that there is a group that claimed responsibility for
these events and there are also
parliamentarians who are requesting the
application of the anti-terrorism law. Your
government opened up to modifying this law.
and why are they now
open to modifying it Thank you
very much
We had a very good meeting yesterday with a
parliamentarian from all the
political sectors of Araucanía and Bío Bío
to specifically deal with
violence in the area
and
we were reviewing the strategy,
also seeing and telling them about the different
intervention areas that the
government has both from the perspective of
the prosecution of crime
as well as from the perspective of
investment and social dialogue regarding
the antiterrorist law the developed countries
that have had
expressions of this type have
modern antiterrorist laws
and the problem with the one that chile has today
is that it is ineffective
and not only is it ineffective, but when
chile has been used it has been condemned
by international organizations
for the misuse that has been given to it.
So therefore I want to make it
very clear  So that there is no doubt,
and that is how the parliamentarians
of Araucanía understood it, in particular yesterday,
we are not against having
anti-terrorist legislation.
of modifications to the current legislation
during the second semester This is a
problem that has been debated at length
in other countries
and therefore we have to learn from
that comparative experience.
I want you to know that we are going to
use all the tools that
the law gives us
every  tools without any kind
of complex to persecute those who
carry out attacks, plant bombs and
intimidate the population
With those who claim that through the
violence of bombings they will be able to
achieve something so profoundly
wrong
and the full weight of the state
of the  law and in front of them the
Chilean state has no fissures
I think I have answered the
question explicitly Thank you very much
we thank both authorities and
we invite the delegations attending
the Mont varas room to participate in the
cocktail offered in honor of the president
of the European commission Mrs. Úrsula
fonderlayen  Thank you very much and good
afternoon
[Applause]